rob d'agathe aux pros alors il faut vous
voyez cette vidéo regardez bien la tête
de bouder away quand il découvre la rode
d'agathe gens me donnent la vie de
francis eric le tue aussi j'ai voir ce
site était dans le prime elle portait
une robe noire qui était quelque peu
transparente vraiment pas plus que
d'habitude ça a beaucoup fait parler
d'elle regardez c'est parti 19 avril
2018 des pmp fête ses 80 ans sur ces
vies sur le plateau la fête bat son
plein
la preuve tous les chroniqueurs ont le
sourire tous sauf une à gâteau proulx et
comme on dit dans le milieu tunisien
aura sera alors elle décide brusquement
de se placer aux côtés du saltimbanque
cyril hanouna vouloir tue pas côtés de
diego d'en donner
et soudain c'est le drame le monde
entier va découvrir que la créatrice du
blog à la mode
osef point cool porte une tenue pour le
moins affriolante
pour preuve cette réaction de
l'humoriste booder la robe transparente
agathe a provoqué sur twitter un raz de
marée
salut je crois que tu as oublié une
partie de ta robe en bois tennis à
travers celle-ci smiley qui pleure de
rire comment elle s'habille et agathe on
voit son popotin sérieux elle aurait dû
venir à poil vue là j'le de sa robe
agathe au proulx décide de répondre pour
l'animatrice de ketchup mayo la coupe
est pleine
la tenue d'un gâteau proulx était-elle
trop posé les violentes réactions sur
les réseaux sociaux sont elles
justifiées
et surtout est-ce que bouder a bandé
toutes ces questions auxquelles
l'inspecteur baba va tenter de répondre
effectivement
alors agathe agathe
les questions sont simples ça fait
beaucoup parler alors agathe vous avez
donc l'arrêt sur image dans la lourdeur
alors agathe vous avez réagi
on l'a vu sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
une habile à qui vous a donné un conseil
là dessus se justifie même pas neuf
voilà elle t'a dit il rappelant qu'ils
vont ainsi je remercie n'aura d'ailleurs
quand on a parlé aussi très très
gentiment yala plan qui vous ont soutenu
franchement est ce qu'on reconduit ou
prenez cette polémique autour de la
tenue de la gare du nord en visite on
n'était qu'au nord c'est con qu'elle
n'est pas remis non mais agathe sata
gênés ou pas franchement ce serait
blessé ou pas du tout non mais en fait
c'est pas c'est pas drôle du tout c c c
et e on le vit tous ici mais c'est un
déferlement de tweets insultant parce
que la vie évidemment on n'a pas passé
les on n'a pas bien sûr on est dans la
zone des tempêtes dans la rigole a
évidemment mais non vrai c'est pas drôle
du tout quoi c'est vrai ça vous a gêné
allez la violence des réactions
évidemment moi j'ai une question me pose
est pourquoi en fait qu'est ce qu'on
faisait à côté de moi mathieu avait pris
ma place oui vous avez dit je vais te
mettre une chaise et donc voilà j'étais
match vous croyez alors par le mail au
balo est ce que vous croyez vraiment que
chasse tente de chaises genre ici lâche
au covan alors on a quoi on a du
merisier c'est pour un gars de broue da
non je ne suis pas fan mais vous aviez
des deux jeunes scouts et oui c'est vrai
quand je suis quand je suis rentré l'été
j'ai trajet pas bougé justice et si ça
vous a gêné je ne le referai plus a mis
bas vous pouvez venir russie ou
d'inquiéter pro ça va est ce que ça vous
a choqué bon la polémique qui puisse les
de la réponse daguerre qui vous angoisse
et ça nous ferait que de la tenue on a
dû tout on est largué parti de la tenue
à la catégorie aladin est l'ami de voile
à ella ella revenir à une blanche c'est
dans la turbine et oui je suis choqué
par la polémique et je défends
totalement agathe mais pour elle c'est
très dur à vivre franchement c'est pour
les mises là où on est attaqué sur le
physique pour les femmes c'est
extrêmement difficile
il y en a marre de ça sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est la partie des réseaux
sociaux qui en ce moment dépasse les
bonbons dont j'ai accéléré qu'on nous
donnait rien je sais pas j'ai envie
d'avoir ton avis vous êtes vous avez de
bonnes relations ce moment ouais mais je
pense qu'à un moment donné où quand on
met un décolleté ou cours montre ses
fesses on sait très bien pertinemment
pouvoir gérer on n'est pas d'accord avec
les réseaux sociaux mais on sait que ça
va arriver
donc soit on l'aimé et on assume de se
prendre des rafales dans la tronche ou
soit en mai pas et à ce moment là bas on
n'aura pas ce retour c'est pas con moi
je répondrai pas mais moi quand je mets
des décolletés je sais qu'à un moment
donné des fois je vais m'en prendre dans
la tronche c'est pas grave c'est la vie
justement a répondu que la saison
totalement alors là si on ne veut pas de
ça justement c'est ce qu'elle a fait
puisqu'elle a fumé derrière elle à dix
ou si on adore jaoui
la grèce a travail franchement du fauga
continue à gaga agathe a suivi puisque
regarde ce qu elle a dit je m'habille
comme j'en ai envie
à la télé pas à la télé où il peut
m'arriver d'être sexy et c'est cool de
se sentir sexy en fait non mais se
plaire à soi même revendiquer une
certaine liberté
jaune à la faute en gros je vous emmerde
airs lavaud la presse de relayer le
harcèlement et part du gâteau mollet
label fondé la kth chercher un molière
sur la vie de la mère c'est quoi ce truc
c'est déjà twitté mois à semoy des trucs
comme ça mais c'est fou voilà qui est
adressé ouais mais après c'est quand
même un débat très compliqué parce que
du harcèlement oui harcèlement ça veut
dire quoi c'est à dire qu'il ya plein de
thuy qui vont dans le même sens mais
cuite and sweet qui te disent teman
autorités ce twin intelligente et belle
c'est du harcèlement positif que dans un
sens à l'orgue à 12 h au quai la tenue
d'un gadoua lâche la tenure non mais
c'est pas vous que je parle je parle de
téléspecteurs mais pas tout seul
regardez regardez banon elle fait la
touche non on va regarder dont dior non
à 65%
comprenez vous la polémique autour de
l'arop d'agathe ou non à 70 employés
dont vous êtes content
ouais